my job on on Ghost Recon Phantom is as
the lead animator I create character
animations I make our characters move
reload weapons jump over things take
cover the game wouldn't work without
animations and animations wouldn't work
with other code it's a friendly constant
battle to make sure that we get things
working properly actually I'm kind of
surrounded by programmers were really
placed with them so yes Kelly book me
all the time so we have a new animation
you need to put it in the games my job
is to make sure that we only need a
small quick small adjustment so the
animation book will even with the new
characters and new assets so I tend to
do much more research online just
looking at videos like actions it's
quite difficult to get your hands on an
sa80 assault rifle here in Singapore
however what is good is be able to act
out the motion yourself because then you
realize that the animation you're doing
is is believable or not or natural I do
tend to make a bigger fool of myself
inside the office yeah that's kind of
prancing around and doing actions I
think the guys around here are kind of
got used to me so you can see him like
taking a fake gun and actually posing
and testing out some of the moves and
it's kind of funny but it's very useful
I've been working with jelly like all
these years for four movements and I
need to have this exact sound with its
animation and it all comes through these
batches game design animation than sound
whenever I'm in the planning stage of
doing an animation I will Cooler the
bees and I'll explain what I want the
character to do and what I imagine the
current is going to be doing so it gives
him a bit of a heads up so that he can
be thinking about audio wise what he's
going to do and start to prep for that
once I finished the animation I sit back
down with him and show him through and
then he takes over and that's all the
good stuff what sound design is
paramount for any game really but
Khan phantoms in particular because it
really adds to the sense of immersion
you really feel like you are on the
battlefield with your teammates fighting
for the win for Ghost Recon phantoms all
the weapons start any calls great list
of guns so we start processing by you
know editing adding effects ringing it
loud making is this it distinct from the
other guns and we have we hook it up
with the artists 3d model and animators
animation for the reloads and that's it
there's naturally an immense amount of
creativity on Ghost Recon phantoms
everybody can contribute to ideas and
feedback beach is constantly assaulted
by people who come back to him and tell
him out you've made that change you make
this change of value that piece of music
you've added this feedback because we
can because we care what I want to do is
I always want to please the players
sounded I really like is the sound of
the ak-12 I've been able to create mark
something that is me but it's not
something like a blend both and that
makes us proud the slightest mistake
this is religious in fact and an extreme
long-term memory people remember you for
what you've done